[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مسائكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
اوكرانيا تقول انها تتواصل مع شركائها
للحصول على صواريخ بعيده المدى وطائرات
الهجوميه
امريكا صادرت 5000 سلاح ايراني كانت متجهه
للحوت خلال شهرين
في موافقتي 43 دوله السعوديه تفوز
باستضافه بطوله كاس امم اسيا عام 2027
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
[موسيقى]
عليه
حياته ترفيه السعوديه تقيم اليوم حفله
غنائيه لتكريم الفنان السعودي الراحل طلال
مداح
في ختام رحلته البريطاني ماركه مارك
ايفانز يكشفوا للرابعه تجربته ولتكشف
الاستكشافيه في السعوديه
حياكم الله قال الكريم لان الصواريخ طويله
المدى التي قيل انها ضمن حزمه مقبله من
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه لاوكرانيا
ستفاق لكنها لم تمنع روسيا من تحقيق
اهدافها واضاف كريم لان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمي بوتين ليس لديه اي خططه لعقد
محادثات مع نظيره الامريكي في الوقت
الحالي
قال نائب هو المستشار الالماني روبرت
هابيك ان تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله
سيكون امرا خاطئا واعتبر هابيك في مقابله
تلفزيونيه انه ليس من الصواب توريد مقاتله
الان ورد على سؤال من احد الصحفيين لتوضيح
ما اذا كان ذلك الان فقط او بشكل عام اوضح
نائب المستشار الالماني انه بشكل عام لا
يعتبر هذا صحيحا
اصر الرئيس الوزراء النرويجي يناس جار
صوره في مقابله مع وكاله فرانسبريس على ان
بلاده لا تستغل الحرب في اوكرانيا لتحقيق
ارباح اضافيه باشاره الى اندرويد ستصبح
قريبا واحده من اكبر الجهات المانحه لكيف
مع حزمه مساعدات القادمه
لا يمكنني قبول ذلك كانت النرويج لمده 50
عاما مستكشفا وبائعا لموارد الطاقه
الرئيسي ولكن في عالم كبير من المنتجين
السوق هو من يحدد الاسعار
ومن دونيت ينضم الينا مراسل للعربيه رائد
الاخضر رائد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض بدايه ما الجديد
في محوري باخموت اوكلادور الحديث ايضا عن
سيطره قوه فاجنر على بلدتين رئيسيتين
مهمتين هناك
بالفعل يعني المحور الاكثر سخونه ومحور
باخم في شمال مقاطعه
اعلنت سلطات المنطقه اليوم عن اكمال الطوق
على مدينه باخم طبعا نعلم بانها مدينه
باخ- منذ زمن مطوق لكن الاعلان الرسمي جاء
اليوم بعد ان اعلنت السلطات المحليه بانها
قطعت الطرق الممتده من خلف مدينه همم
طاخمه الناحيه الغربيه حيث الامدادات
العسكريه من مدينتي قسطنطينه وايضا مدينه
التي تعمل يعني عبر الطرق السريعه على
امداد القوات الاوكرانيه المتمرزه في
مدينه
يعني امدادات
بالفعل همم اعلن سلطات المحليه اليوم
اكمال الطوق على مدينه كما ان هو اتفاغنر
ما زالت تقاتل في المناطق الجنوبيه خاصه
من المدينه بلده ايفانافكا فيها قتال
شوارع بعد انطلاقات من بلده كليشكا التي
يعني تعتبر معقل القوات الروسيه التي
تنطلق ل- ايه يعني تحضير عمليات اقتحام
وتقتحم المدينه من الناحيه الجنوبيه عبر
ايفانكا ااه بالفعل المعارك الاكثر سخونه
في ذلك المحور كما ان شمال المدينه همم
يشهد تقدم للقوات الروسيه لكن ليس ناحيه
باقي انما بالناحيه العكسيه شمالا بعد
سيفرس هناك عده بلدات سيطره عليها كما
اسلفت نايف همم يعني القوات الروسيه
والقوات تتقدم
بلدتين اللتان سيطرتا عليهما همم بالفعل
هما على الطريق السريع الذي ايضا يوصل
الامدادات من سيرفر الى محاور مختلفه حيث
تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه لكن قبل الدخول
في محور اخر لابد من ان الضوء كما كنا قبل
قليل على يعني عوده الحياه الى مدينه ااه
دانيسكونا نسلط الضوء على الاحداث التي
شهدتها المدينه لو سمحت لي نايف هنا سقطت
القذائف نحن بجوار مكان اقامتنا في هذا
المنزل وفى هذا الشارع سقطت عده قذائف نرى
الاصلاحات بعد مكان القذائف في الشارع كما
اننا نرى هنا اثار الشضايا التي همم يعني
تنطلق بعد سقوط قديفه او صاروخ كيف انها
لا يعني لا تقتل فقط المنطقه التي تسقط
فيها لكن تتناثر وتتطاير الشطايا من
الصواريخ حتى تصل الى مناطق بعيده جدا
وتضر بمن حولها كانت المنطقه همم فيها حضر
تجول ليلي وفي النهار الناس بطبيعتهم لا
يخرجون اثر المعارك الضاريه وسقوط القذائف
باعداد كبيره
ربما تشهد المنطقه همم يعني همم عوده
للحياه بشكل تدريجي لكن ما زالت المنطقه
معرضه للخطر خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه سقطت
اقل من 100 قذيفه لا في مناطق متفرقه من
المدينه وضواحيها المعارك مستمره ايضا على
اطراف المدينه في مدن همم اوف ديفكا
ومارينكا وايضا همم
عده مدن فيها معارك ضاريه لكن همم
فقط
لكن السؤال عن المناطق الصراع والمناطق
الدائر فيها القتال في هذه اللحظات كم
تبعد من العاصمه همم
لودي
بالفعل يعني نحن نتحدث عن المناطق الاقرب
التي فيها معارك ضاريه وهي اييي مدن اوف
ديفكا مارينكا كرسناغو روكامايسكا بعض
المناطق لا تبعد سوا سته كيلومترات او
سبعه اذا تحدثنا عن منطقه فيسكي هي ما بعد
المطار من مكان اقامتنا وسط المدينه حتى
مطار دنيتك هو المطار طبعا محطم ومدمر
بالكامل همم منذ عام 2014 ثلاثه كيلومترات
وما بعد المطار هي بلده صغيره تدعى بيسك
اذا تذكر سيطرت عليها القوات الروسيه منذ
اشهر ربما نتحدث عن سته كيلومترات يعني
تتواجد القوات الاوكرانيه سبعه كيلومترات
هناك قواعد وهمم همم اساسات للقوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت مركز خلف حصون وتقصف
المدينه بشكل دائم هي تدعم منطقه برلمان
همم يعني صحه التسميه لكن المدن الابعد
قليلا في محور مختلف هذا هو المحور الغربي
لكن المحور الشمالي الغربي همم من الطبيعي
ان فيه معارك اكثر سخونه وهي مدن همم
مدينتي ماريكا وافديفكا وكرسنال وهناك
قوات يعني اعداد كبيره من القوات
الاوكرانيه ومحصنه منذ عام 2014 2015
وفي ذات السياق قالت موسكو ان واشنطن نسفت
الاساس القانوني لمعاهده ستارت الجديده
للحد من الاسلحه لكن الاتفاق يظل مهما
للغايه لروسيا مهما كان الموقف الحالي هذا
رده من الكريم لن ياتي بعدما اتهمت امريكا
روسيا بانتهاك المعاهده وهي الركيزه
الرئيسيه الاخيره للحد من الاسلحه النوويه
في فتره ما بعد الحرب البارده من خلال رفض
السماح باجراء تفتيش على اراضيها
نقلت صحيفه عن مصادر واشنطن لخمسه او عن
مصادره واشنطن 53
قولها ان البحريه او قولها ان البحريه
الفرنسيه صادرت اسلحه ايرانيه كانت متجهه
الى الحوثي في اليمن في يناير واشارت
الصحيفه الى مصادره فرنسا صواريخ موجهه ضد
الدبابات كانت ايران تنقلها للحوثي يبلغ
عددها 20 صاروخا ونقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤولينا قولهم ان باري صادره ثلاثه الاف
بندقيه ايرانيه ونصف مليون طلقه كانت في
طريقها للحوثي
تتاهبوا بريطانيا لاضخم اضراب منذ سنوات
بمشاركه ما يصل الى نصف مليون شخص
الحكومي بالاضافه الى سائقي القطارات
للمطالبه بزياده الاجور بالتزامني مع
ارتفاع معدل التضخم بنسبه تتجاوز 10%
الاضراب والبريطاني هو الاكبر منذ عقد
سيتسببه في تعطيل الاعمال والتاثير على
الاقتصاد وفق الحكومه والتي استعدت له في
سلسله بسلسله من الاجراءات منها رفع وتاهب
الجيش واغلاق المدارس كما ستتوقف خدمات
السكك الحديديه في معظم الحياه البلاد
مراسله العربيه عرب عبد الحق عروب مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض اذن فعلا ابتدات ربما المظاهرات
الاضرابات ايضا كذلك في العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن كيف هي الصوره لديك
ونريد ان نعرف ما هي ابرز ما طالب هؤلاء
المتظاهرين والمطربين
منذ تقريبا نصف ساعه
للعمال المطربين عن العمل من مختلف
القطاعات بداوا من منطقه وهم متجهين الان
الى مقر الحكومه في تن داونز 3 اترك
الصوره لتشاهد هذه المسيره طبعا فيها يعني
نقابات تابعه لقطاع التعليم هناك نقابات
تابعه للنقل وايضا نرى نقابات تابعه
لمختلف القطاعات من همم الخدمه المدنيه
طبعا هذا القطاع الذي يضرب همم اليوم يشمل
حوالي 100,000 موظف وعامل من مختلف
الدوائر الحكوميه حوالي ال 133 دائره
ووكاله حكوميه منهم خبر السواحل منهم حارس
الحدود همم يعني همم الذين طبعا يحل محلهم
عناصر من الجيش طبعا هناك الى جانب اضراب
عمال الخدمه المدنيه هناك اضراب للمعلمين
هذا الاضراب هو الاكبر منذ حوالي الثلاثه
عقود يشارك فيه نحو المئه الف معلم ومن
ال- يعني المتوقع ان يؤثر على حوالي
23,000 مدرسه في مختلف انحاء انجلترا
وويلز طبعا يعني نحن نعلم بان ان النقابات
تطالب رفع الاجور اا يقولون بان ساعات
العمل طويله الرواتب بالكاد تكفي عشرات
الالاف من هؤلاء بحسب النقابات يعتمدون
باته على بنوك الطعام وبالتالي هم غير
قادرين على تحمل تكاليف واعباء الحكومه
طبعا هذه المسيره التي نراها تمتد لحوالي
البضعه كيلومترات تتجه نحو مقر الحكومه في
تن داونز 3 من المتوقع ان يكون هناك
احتجاج لها هؤلاء مطالبه الحكومه برفع
الوجود نحن نع انا الحكومه ملتزمه او يعني
همم ملتزمه بموقفها همم همم الذي يقول
بانهم يعني بان الحكومه غير قادره او لا
لا يوجد المال الكافي لتحقيق مطالبها كيف
ستعامل مع هذه الاضطرابات او مع هؤلاء
المحتاجين اذا كانت غير قادره ماليا على
همم يعني الايفا بهذه المطالبات بتحقيق
طبعا همم يعني همم رغبات هؤلاء ال- ال-
المطربين كيف ستعامل الحديث كذلك عن قانون
ربما يمرر في مجلس الاوردات همم القانون
يعني يجهز التعامل مع المظاهرات او مع
الضرباتهم
طبعا يعني الحكومه متمسكه جدا بموقفها من
عدم رفع الاجور تقول بان الازمه الاساسيه
لها او الاولويه الاساسيه لها هي اييي خفض
نسبه التضخم الذي بالتالي تقول انه قد يحل
مشكله الاجور او تكاليف المعيشه هنا في
بريطانيا وكما ذكرت بالفعل تتجه الحكومه
تذهب الى يعني
تمرير اتحاول تمرير مشروع قانون ضد همم ضد
الاضطرابات هذا المشروع القانون مر عبر
مجلس العموم طبعا لكن نحن نعلم مجلس
العموم له يعني الاغلبيه لحزب المحافظين
وبالتالي كان من المتوقع ان ان يتم تمريره
ولكن مناقشه هذا مشروع القانون هذا في
مجلس الوردات هو ما قد يصد به اعتراض
العديد من من اعضاء مجلس الوردات الذي
يعني فيه ناس او فيه اعضاء من احزاب
مختلفه همم طبعا نحن نعلم بانا هو في
الحلقه ربما الاخيره من
المناقشه كان هناك مناقشه لهذا لمشروع
القانون هذا اا في الامس ولكن النتيجه لم
تظهر بعد يعني نحن بانتظار ان ارى اذا كان
هذا مشروع القانون هذا سيء مره طبعا
النقابات تعتبر هذا مشروع القانون غير
ديمقراطي ولا يحفظ حقوقهم يعني هم يقولون
بانهم الاضراب هو حق مشروع بالنسبه لهم
خاصه بانهم يعني يشعرون هم اكثر من يشعر
حسب قولهم بتكاليف المعيشه التي همم تضرب
بريطانيا منذ العام الماضي نحن نعلم بان
نسبه التضخم وصلت الى ما يزيد عن 10% الان
هم يطالبون برفع اجورهم بنسبه تتساوى
تتناسب مع معدل التضخم هذا ونحن نعلم بان
الحكومه متوسط العروض المقدمه حتى الان ما
بين اربعه وخمسه بالمئه همم له سنتين
القادمه ولكن تعتبر ان نقابات ان هذه
النسب مصدقيله وربما غير منصف بحقهم
شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات التفاصيل على
الصوره التي نقلتيها لنا من شارع العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن مراسله العربيه عبره الحق
شكرا لك
رابع مستمره وبها بعد قليل ايضا
السعوديه تعتمد تسميه العام الحالي بعام
الشاعر العربي
حياكم الله من جديد نذهب لمتابعه هذه
الصور
لزياره وزير الدفاع
الالماني
قاعده للنيتو في الليتوانيا اذا يزور لواء
الدبابات ليبارت وهي الدبابات التي من
المتوقع ان تسلم بعد دول الناتو هذه
الدبابات اوكرانيا بعد جدلا بشان هذا خلال
الاسابيع والشهر الماضي دبابات اليوبارد 2
الالمانيه اذا وزير الدفاع الالماني يزور
لواء الدبابات ليفارد اثنان
اعلن الاتحاد الاسيوي لكره القدم فوز
السعودي ياتي بتنظيم كاس اسيا 2027 خلال
اجتماع الجمعيه العموميه للاتحاد القاري
في المنامه وذلك بعد تصويت 43 دوله
وامتناعي فلسطين وتركمانستان عن التصويت
هذا وقت تخطط السعوديه لاستضافه مواجهات
البطوله في ثلاث مدن
وعشر استعدادات من بينها من ثلاث استعداد
جديده
اذا للمره الاولى في تاريخها السعوديه
تفوز رسميا باستضافه كاس امم اسيا 20 27
في نظره سريعه على الملف الذي قدمته
المملكه استضافه البطوله اولا ستتوزع
المباريات وبعثات المنتخبات المشاركه على
المدن الثلاث الكبرى الرياض وجده والدمام
التي ستضم عشره استادات رياضيه نصفها في
الرياض وثلاثه في الدمام وملعبان في جده
ثلاثه ملاعب جديده سيتم انشاءها استعدادا
للبطوله اثنان في الرياض احدهما في القديه
والاخر في شمال العاصمه بالاضافه الى بناء
ملعب جديد في الدمام استاد الملك فهد
بالرياض سيلبس حله جديده بدا العمل عليها
منذ اليوم حيث سيشهد اعمال تطوير وترميم
تشمل زياده سعته الاستيعابيه من 56,000
تفرج الى 80 الف متفرج من خلال ازاله
مضمار الجري وبناء مدرج جديد ليكون الملعب
الاكبر في البلاد من ناحيه سعته
الجماهيريه كذلك ملعب الامير فيصل بن فهد
بالرياض بحسب الملف المقدم سيشهد اعمال
اعاده تهيئه بالكامل تشمل مضاعفه سعته
الاستيعابيه من 22 الى
44,000 متفرج وازاله المضمار بالاضافه الى
تطوير مرافق الملعب وبناء مظلات جديده
فيما سيكون مرسول مبارك خامس ملاعب الرياض
وفي شرق البلاد تحديدا في الدمام ستتم
اعاده تاهيل ملعب الامير محمد بن فهد
وزياده طاقته الاستيعابيه من 22000 الى
30,000 متفرج كذلك ملعب الامير سعود بن
جلوي براكه سيشهدوا اعمالا تطويريه تستهدف
مضاعفه السعه الجماهيريه من 11,000 الى 22
الفا متفرج والى غرب البلاد حيث سيكون
لجده نصيب من استضافه منافسات البطوله من
خلال ستاد الملك عبد الله الجوهره المشعه
وملعب الامير عبد الله الفيصل الذي انتهى
ترميمه قبل فتره قصيره
ومعنا من المنامه موفد العربيه نايف
الثقيل نايف مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض ااا مبروك فوز
السعوديه اولا بهذه الاستضافه نريد ان
نعرف عن الملف السعودي اكثر ما الذي تضمنه
هذا الملف الاعلانات ايضا حتى الجديده
التي كانت اليوم عن همم بين استاد جديده
عن اعاده تاهيل بعض السادات الموجوده في
السعوديه
اهلا ااه نايف مبروك دعني في البدايه
اتحدث عن تقييم اللجنه التي قامت بزياره
ال ال المنشات السعوديه
وقيمت الملف السعودي اليوم رغم انه الملف
الوحيد ولكن حسب الانظمه الاتحاد الاسيوي
لابد ان يطرح الملف امام
اعضاء الجمعيه العموميه ويتم بعد ذلك عرض
التقييم الفني والتقييم ثم يبدا التصويت
على همم
اليوم كان التقييم جدا رائع وممتاز للملف
السعودي همم تقييم الاتحاد الاسيوي يعتمد
على ثلاثه تصنيفات عالي المخاطر
المتوسطه مخاطر متدنيه جميع عناصر المخاطر
متوسطه ومخاطر المتدنيه جميع
المؤشرات اللي كانت موجوده في الملف
السعودي حصلت على مخاطر المتدنيه ما يعني
ذلك ان الملف همم ثقه الفريق الذي قام
بالزياره همم السعوديه في الفتره الم في
ما يخص الملاعب نعلم جميعا انه في ديسمبر
الماضي اعلنت الهند انسحابه وهي كانت
الدوله الاخيره المنافسه للسعوديه منذ ذلك
الوقت السعوديه بدات بالفعل على العمل على
تهيئه ملاعبها لاستضافه البطوله حسب حديث
سمو الامير عبد العزيز الفيصل وزير في هذا
انه بالفعل بدات الاعمال منذ مده انتهت
مرحله التصاميم والمخططات همم وايضا الخطه
الزمنيه لاعمال المشروع تبقى فقط للاعلان
عن هذه التفاصيل ومن ثم البدء فعليا همم
في همم تنفيذ هذه
المشاريع بشكل كامل في نقطه مهمه اذا كان
ايضا الامير عبد العزيز انه السعوديه
ملزمه بان
تستفتح جميع الملاعب وتنهي جميع همم
التحسينات في الملاعب القائمه حاليا قبل
عام او في عام 20 25 وان تكون همم متاحه
لاقامه المناشطه الرياضيه واستضافه
مباريات اتحدث عن تقريبا عامين فقط امام
السعوديه لانجاز هذه الملفات وبحسب حديث
همم وزير الرياضه الذي يمثل كامله لانجاز
هذا المشروع وان تكون الملاعب جاهزه
بالكامل لعام 20 25 اي قبل استضافه
البطوله الملاعب الجديده كذلك
الملاعب الجديده وايضا جميع الملاعب التي
موجوده في الملف لابد ان تكون جاهزه 20 25
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه المعلومات من
المنامه
الثقيل على كل هذه هي التفاصيل
استقبل وزير الحج والعمره السعوديه توفيق
الربيعه وفدا عراقيه في منفذ جديده عرعر
حيث كان على راس الوقت العراقي رئيس
الهيئه العليا للحج والعمره سامي المسعودي
ومسؤولين اخرين وبحث الجانبان الملفات
الثالث الاهتمام المشترك بين البلدين
وتسهيلات الممنوحه للحجاج والمعتمرين يشار
الى ان اعداد المعتمرين القادمين من
العراق تجاوزت 120 الف معتمر مندوبه موسم
العمره وحتى الان
عبد الواحد الحميد مراسل العربيه ينضم
الينا منفذ جديده عرعر عبد الواحد مرحبا
بك معي في هذه النشره نريد ان نعرف اكثر
عن منفذ جداده عرعر عن هذه الجوله ايضا
هذه الجوله ايضا والوفد السعودي تفاصيل
لقائه مع الوفد العراقي والذي كان راسه من
جانب السعودي وزير الحج والعمره توفيق
الربيع
اهلا بك نايف نعم بالتاكيد نحن هنا يعني
تبعنا الزياره العراقيه الى المنفذ حيث
التقى رئيس هيئه الحج والعمره العليا سامي
المسعودي التقاء وزير الحج والعمره
السعودي توفيق ربيعه
وتحدثها حول مدى استعداد طبعا الجانب
السعودي لاستقبال المعتمرين في موسم
العمره نعلم ان منفذ جديده عرعر كان على
مدى شهرين تقريبا يستقبل المعتمرين بشكل
شبه يومي سالنا المتواجدون المتواجدين هنا
في طبعا مركز وزاره الحج والعمره داخل
منفذ جديده عرعر سالناهم عن اعداد
الحافلات التي تصل يوميا من العراق يقولون
بان يعني تصلح يعني الى 30 حرف الى كل يوم
همم كل هذه الاستعدادات التي يقوم بها
العاملون في منفذ جديد عرعر يعني بشكل
يومي لاستقبال المعتمرين اضافه الى ذلك
نايف يعني نشاهد ان العام يعني اذا كان
همم الواحد يعني انه الاجراءاتك الكاميرا
حتى نشوف المكان اكثر وتتفضل في حديثك
يعني تكمل
نعم نعم فيما يتعلق بكذلك همم العاملين في
مركز وزاره الحج والعمره الذين يقومون
بانهاء اجراءاتي وصول المعتمرين ودخولهم
الى السعوديه حيث يتم التاكد من التاشيرات
بالاضافه الى التاكد من التصاريح اللازمه
ويتم التاكد حتى من همم يعني وصولهم الى
همم ودخولهم الى السعوديه حيث يتم همم
التاكد من التصاريح الاسكان بالنسبه
للمعتمرين القادمين من العراق حيث كما
تعلم نايف اكثر من 120,000 معتمر عراقي
دخلوا عبر هذا المنفذ خلال الفتره الماضيه
ضمن موسم العمره هذا العام
ولا زال يعني
بيعمل على مدار العام طبعا وفي ارقام
ومعلومات واحصائيات ايضا كذلك عن هذا
المنفذ منذ ان بدا يستقبل الحجاج
والمعتمرين يعني بشكل مستمر على مدار
السلام ماذا بهذا الخصوص ايضا حتى عبد
الواحد
نعم نايف نحن سالنا وزير الحج والعمره
السعودي توفيق الربيعه عن جاهزيه هذا
المنفذ وعم اذا كان سوف يستمر باستقبال
المعتمرين يوميا وجاب له الوزير بانه هذا
المنفذ يستقبل المعتمرين من العراق بشكل
يومي وهو على جازيه تامه واشار كذلك الى
الاعداد الكبيره التي تدخل من العراق الى
السعوديه ضمن موسم العمره هذا العام اضافه
الى ان همم المنفذ حسب ما قاله الوزير سوف
يكون جاهزا لاستقبال الحجاج كذلك في موسم
الحج هذا العام الذي سيكون باعداد كبيره
ما قبل كورونا كما تعلم حسب ما اعلنته
وزاره الحج والعمره في وقت سابق بان
الاعداد سوف تعود كما كانت همم عليه من
قبل
التجهيزات هنا في منفذ جديده عرعر كما
ذكرت لك نايف يعني يستقبلون المعتمرين
بشكل يومي من الجانب العراقي سواء
الجوازات او حتى الجمارك وغيره من الجهات
العامله في منفذ الجديده نايف كل هذه
التفاصيل نتابعها بشكل مستمر معكم المنفذ
انه تبع ايضا في صوره المعتمرين ايضا
والزوار من خلقك شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل عبد الواحد الحميد
مراسل العربيه من منفذ جديده عرعر
اصدر مجلس الوزراء السعودي يوم امس
موافقته على تسميه عام 2023 في عام الشعر
العربي ومن جانبها اوضحت وزاره الثقافه
السعوديه ان تسميه
2023 بعام الشاعر العربي تهدف لاثراء
الابداع الشعري المتطور والمستدام ايضا
كذلك وتعزيز ما كانت الشعر العربي في
ثقافه الفرد في الاضافه الى ابراز مكونه
الحضاري الشعري وتجدره في تاريخ الجزيره
العربيه
معناها من الرياض الرئيسيه لهيئه الادب
والنشر والترجمه الدكتور محمد حسن علوان
دكتور محمد مساء الخير حياك الله معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وداني اسفل في
البدايه بعد ان وافق مجلس الوزراء على
تسميه هذا العام عام 2023 عام الشعر
العربي لماذا تم اختيار الشعر العربي عام
مساء النور وشكرا للاستضافه بطبيعه الحال
لم ياتي هذا الاختيار تاكيدا للقيمه
المحوريه للشعر العربي في ثقافه العربيه
بشكل عام والبعد تاريخي والامتدادات
الجذريه لحضوره الشعر خصوصا في ثقافه
الجزيره العربيه التي كانت وما زالت موطن
للشعر والشعراء همم
القرون طويله
وياتي عام الشعر العربي تحديدا بعد عامين
قامت من خلالهم وزاره الثقافه بالاحتفاء
بالمكونات الثقافيه الاصيله في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه همم عايشنا عام الخط
العربي وبعد ذلك عامل القهوه السعوديه وكل
ما يعكس اعتزازنا بالهويه الوطنيه
والعناصر الثقافيه السعوديه والعربيه وذلك
ياتي بطبيعه الحال تحقيقا لمستهدفات رؤيه
المملكه 2030 التي تتضمنت ابراز الهويه
الوطنيه الثقافيه السعوديه ضمن
المستهدفاتتها
بالحديث عن المستهدفات ما الذي تهدف اليه
الوزاره وزاره الثقافه في المقام الاول
وايضا كمان هيئه الادب والنشر والترجمه من
يعني اختيار الشعر العربي هذا العام حتى
يكون هو عام همم او حتى يكون عام 2023
عاما للشعر العربي
نهدي في تحديدا لا تعزيز مكانه الشعر
العربي في ثقافه الفرد اثراء الابداع
الشعري المتطور والمستدام وابراز المكون
الحضاري الشعري الحاضر في تاريخ الجزيره
العربيه تحديدا كما تعلم الجزيره العربيه
همم هي الموطن الام للشعر العربي الجزء
الاعظم من تاريخنا الشعري حدث همم في
الجزيره العربيه شعراءنا العظام همم عاشوا
في الجزيره العربيه وكتبه همم تاريخ همم
الشعر بشكل عام في الجزيره العربيه ولعلنا
نهدف من هذا العام الى تصنيط الضوء على
هذا الحضور التاريخي للجزيره العربيه في
عالم الشعر وامتداداته همم عبر همم مختلف
مناطق العالم العربي بعد ذلك بالتوفيق لكم
يا دكتور شكرا جزيلا همم لك من الرياض
الرئيس التنفيذي لهيئه الاداب والنشر
والترجمه الدكتور محمد حسن علوان
في لقاء مع العربيه
التي بدات من شرق السعوديه الى 13
الذي يمكن للانسان ان ينهي فيه رحلته عبر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه على مدى 28 يوما
سافرنا من الخير في المنطقه الشرقيه الى
الرياض وصولا الى جده اسوه بالرحله التي
قام بها عام
المستكشف البريطاني فلبيني رحلتنا بدات في
منتصف شهر نوفمبر بين السير على الاقدام
وانتظار الجمال كما ركبنا احيانا الاخرى
السيارات ذات الدفع الرباعي
اعجبني كثيرا هو رؤيه التغيرات الكبيره
التي شهدت السعوديه عشته هنا في اواخر
التسعينيات من القرن الماضي والفرق كانه
في بلدين مختلفين تماما لكن الامر الذي لم
يتغير هو كرم الضيافه ومنذ اليوم الاول
الذي وصلنا فيه الى الخير استقبلنا بالتمر
وهي ضيافه التي رافقتنا على امتداد رحلتنا
حتى وصلنا مدينه جده لكل من لم يجري
السعوديه يجب ان تاتي لزيارتها لاسباب
العده اولها سهوله القدوم حيث يستطيع
الشخص ان يحصل على تاشيره زياره
الالكترونيه في غضون دقائق اما ثانيا
فالزازير سيشاهد بلد استثنائيا لما يحوزه
من مواقع اثريه وتضاريس طبيعيه جذابه
ومعالم ثقافيه وتنوع للمناخ والغطاء
النباتي كما سيحظى بحراره استقبال منقطعه
النظير
وقع صندوق السعوديه للتنميه مذكره تتفاهم
مع وزاره الماليه في سلطنه عمان لتمويل
المشروع انشاء البنيه التحتيه للمنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخاصه بالظاهره وذلك اجماع
باجمالين يقدر بمليار ومئتين مليون ريال
توقيع المذكره جاء خلال انعقاد منتدى
الاستثمار السعودي العماني الذي انطلق
اليوم في الرياض وشهد توقيع 3 10 اتفاقيه
في عده مجالات منها النفط والطاقه
المتجدده والسياحه
اعلنا ثاني نيابه العامه السعوديه عن
توجيه الاتهام لثلاثه الوافدين بتهمه
الاحتيال المالي وذلك لتورطهم في استخدام
شرائح اتصالات مختلفه وتمرير المكالمات
بطريقه غير نظاميه باستخدام اجهزه تم
تهريبها عن طريق دوله مجاوره حيث قام
بواسطتها بارتكاب عده جرائم احتلال مالي
النيابه كشفت كذلك بانه وبتفتيش مسكن
المتهمين تم العثور على 200 و20 كرت شريحه
اتصال و 170 شريحه اتصال مفعله وثلاثه
اجهزه ارسال لتحويل ارقام الاتصال الدوليه
الى ارقام المحليه هذا وقد تم احاله
المتهمين حسب بين النيابه الى المحكمه
المختصه للمطالبه بالعقوبات المقرره في
نظام مكافحه الاحتلال الماليه
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
رئيسه هيئه الترفيه يدشر منطقه فياريال
ومنتصف فبراير موعدا لفتح الابواب رسميه
حياكم الله من جديد تستضيف الرياضه شهر
القادم مؤتمر المستقبل منظمات التربيه
والثقافه والعلوم في القرن الحادي
والعشرين بمشاركه عدد من المنظمات الدوليه
الكبرى سيحضر المؤتمر الذي يعد الاول من
نوعه بمشاركه جهه دوليه بارزه ومؤثره في
مجالات متعدده العلوم والتقنيه والتمويل
التنموي وذلك لمناقشه التحديات والفرص
التي تشهدها قطاعات التربيه والثقافه
والعلوم واثرها على المجتمعات سيجمع
المؤتمر قاده المنظمات الدوليه متعدده
الاطراف في مجالات التربيه والثقافه
والعلوم معانا ضرائهم من ممثلين عن بنوك
التنميه الدوليه والاقليميه والمؤسسات
الاكاديميه وقطاع الاعمال بهدفه تمكين
التعاوني لدعم تلك القطاعات
تشهد الرياض مساء اليوم اقامه امسيه ليله
صوت الارض والتي تنظمها هيئه العامه
للترفيه لتكريم الفنان السعودي الراحل
طلال مداح وذلك بمشاركه عدد كبير من
الفنانين العرب وكان عبد الله نجل الفنان
طلال مداح قد اعلن في وقت سابق عن موافقه
العائله على دعوه رئيس الهيئه العامه
للترف باقامه حفل تكريم للراحل
السعوديه في حفل استثنائي منطقه فيها رياض
والتي تضم مجموعه من المطاعم والعلامات
التجاريه العالميه بالاضافه الى فندق
عالمي وسينما وسط طابعا عمرانيا مختلف
المنطقه الترفيهيه السعوديه استغرقت نحو
20 شهرا من البناء لتفاصيلها العمرانيه
التي دمجت متطلبات الحياه الحديثه
واستحضار التراث المعماري الاصيل كما
تحيطها مساحات خضر لاشجار يتجاوز عمرها
850 عاما هيئه الترفيه اوضحت ان منطقه
فيها رياض ستبدا في استقبال زوارها
منتصفها فبراير الجاري بتشكيله من
الفعاليات والعروض الحيه
[موسيقى]
تتواصلوا اعمال مبادره الرياض الخضراء في
واختلف الاحياء بين تشجير وزراعه شملت
مساجد ومدارس وشوارع رئيسيه واخرى تابعه
للاحياء نشاهد التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
عند هطول الامطار في موسمي سهيل والوسم
يظهر الفقع الزبيدي وطول الامطار في موسم
المربعانيه يظهر الفقع الخلاسي التفاصيل
في تقويم دائما مع خالد سعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من الرياضات النفسيه المحببه عند العرب
قديما وحديثا لقطه الفقع فنزول المطر في
موسمه وتتابع نزول المطر وان تكون الارض
سريحه لم يعبث بها انسان ولم يطعها حيوان
اذا توافرت هذه الشروط فان الفقع يطلع
فنزول المطر بموسم سهيل والوسم يطلع لنا
الفقع زبيدي وهو الفقع الابيض البارز على
الارض واذا نزل موسم المربعانيه فانه يطلع
لنا الفتح على الخلاسي وهو الفقع الاحمر
المندس على الارض واشهر انواع الفقع
الزبيدي واطعمها اخلاسي وهلنا الاولين
الله يرحمهم يقولون الاخلاصي الراسي
وزويدي والجبال لام البنات تراه هم اللي
يقولونه انا ما قلته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وظهور الفقع دليل قاطع على بدايه الدفء
باطن الارض فالفقع يظل محتبسا في باطنها
طوال فتره الشتاء القارص ومع بدايه شمس
الربيع فانه يظهر على وجه الارض وتباشير
الفجع المسمى بالهوبر يظهر بعد اول مطره
باربعين ليله والفادي على صالح للاكل يظهر
بعد اول مطره ب 70 ليله والفقع فطر
والاكثار منه مضر على باطنيه الانسان
ولهذا العام يقولون لا طلع الفجر
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه
للحصول على صواريخ بعيده المدى والطائرات
الهجوميه
الى فرنسا خمسه الاف سلاح ايراني كانت
متجهه للحوثي خلال شهرين
طيب بموافقه 43 الدوله السعوديه تفوز
باستضافه بطوله كاس امم اسيا 2017
هيئه الترفيه السعوديه تقيم اليوم حفله
غنائيه تكريما للراحل طلال مداح
شكرا لكم لطفي المتابعه نهايه الرابعكم
غدا
[موسيقى]